LOOK, I'M GOING TO GO
THROUGH THIS SLOWLY.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN THIS COP
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC
APPLICATION OF THE LAWS YOU
OUGHT TO BE VERY CONCERNED
TONIGHT AND OUTRAGED.
GENERAL FLYNN'S ENTIRE LIFE
HAS BEEN PUT IN LIMBO FOR AN
ENTIRE YEAR FOR THIS?
I HAVE READ THE ENTIRE
REPORT.
THEY EVEN USED THE LOGAN
ACT.
AND ACTUALLY RARELY EVER
USED OR INVOKED.
HILLARY AND THE ESPIONAGE
ACT, HE HAS LOST HIS HOUSE
BECAUSE HE COULDN'T AFFORD
THE ATTORNEYS.
HE HAD TO SELL HIS HOUSE.
HIS LIFE'S WORK, 33 YEARS OF
SERVING HIS COUNTRY, WASHED
DOWN THE DRAIN FOR THIS?
REPUTATION DESTROYED FOR
THIS?
NOBODY IN THE FBI THOUGHT
THIS MAN LIED.
COMEY DIDN'T THINK SO.
MCCABE DIDN'T THINK.
SO STRZOK OF ALL PEOPLE, HE
DIDN'T THINK SO, AND HE
INTERVIEWED LIEUTENANT
GENERAL FLYNN.
33 YEARS OF SERVICE, FIVE
YEARS IN COMBAT IN IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN.
AND THIS IS THE TREATMENT?
THIS IS THE THANKS THIS
COUNTRY GIVES HIM?
THIS IS WHAT -- THIS IS HOW
WE TREAT PEOPLE?
WHAT KIND OF JUSTICE SYSTEM
IS THIS?
HIS HOUSE NEARLY FACED
BANKRUPTCY, LITERALLY AND
HIS WORLD CRASHES BEFORE HIM
AND HIS ENTIRE FAMILY, AND I
WOULD BET ANY AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT THE ONLY REASON
HE SIGNED THIS DEAL WAS
WELL, IT'S THE SAME OLD
SYSTEM.
WELL, WE MIGHT HAVE TO GO
AFTER YOUR SON WORKED WITH
YOU AND THEN WE ARE GOING TO
INVOKE THE LOGAN ACT WHICH
NOBODY INVOKES TO GO AFTER
HIM.
SO HE COULD HAVE MADE,
INSTEAD OF SERVING HIS
COUNTRY IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR A LOT MORE MONEY.
BUT NOW HE HAS TO SELL HIS
HOUSE, LITERALLY FALL ON THE
SWORD FOR HIS FAMILY.
AND DON'T FORGET, WE KNOW
THAT THEY GOT THROUGH WHAT A
LOT OF THIS INFORMATION,
THROUGH WHAT?
WE KNEW HE WAS THE VICTIM OF
ILLEGAL SURVEILLANCE,
ILLEGAL UNMASKING.
ILLEGAL LEAKING OF RAW
INTELLIGENCE.
WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THOSE CRIMES?
HIS RIGHTS WERE VIOLATED AT
EVERY LEVEL.
NOW, THIS IS A DISGRACE AND
THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
TELLING YOU.
THE GLARING EXAMPLE OF A
TWO-TIERED JUSTICE SYSTEM IN
AMERICA.
IN MUELLER'S SENTENCING MEMO
IT SAYS QUOTE SENIOR
GOVERNMENT LEADERS SHOULD BE
HELD TO THE HIGHEST
STANDARDS.
CAN WE START WITH HILLARY
CLINTON?
AND JAMES COMEY BECAUSE WE
HAVE A LONG LIST OF
DEMOCRATS AND TRUMP HATERS
WHO HAVE LIED UNDER OATH
BEFORE CONGRESS AND HAVE
FACED NO CONSEQUENCES.
FOR EXAMPLE, LONG-TIME
CLINTON AIDE CHERYL MILLS,
HUMA ABEDIN LIED WHEN THEY
TOLD THE FBI INVESTIGATORS
THEY HAD NO KNOWLEDGE OF
HILLARY'S PRIVATE EMAIL
EXCEPT THEY USED IT EITHER
DOJ OFFICIAL BRUCE OHR,
FUSION GPS FOUNDER GLENN
SIMPSON THEY, OF COURSE, ONE
OF THEM WAS LYING DUE TO
THEIR CONTRADICTORY
TESTIMONY.
NOBODY WAS HELD HOSTAGE LIKE
IN FORA YEAR.
DIRTY DOSSIER AUTHOR
CHRISTOPHER STEELE HIS WHOLE
DOSSIER WAS DEBUNKED HE WAS
FIRED FOR LYING TO THE FBI.
STILL WORKING WITH THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND BRUCE
OHR TO GET TO SPECIAL
COUNSEL MUELLER.
JAMES CLAPPER LIED UNDER
OATH ABOUT THE NATIONAL
SURVEILLANCE PROGRAM.
SO TOO DID JOHN BRENNAN ALSO
LIKELY LYING UNDER OATH
ABOUT LEAKING.
AND DOOR FORGET JAMES COMEY
HIMSELF LIED UNDER OATH WHEN
HE SAID THE REPORT ABOUT THE
CLINTON INVESTIGATION HAD
NOT BEEN WRITTEN BEFORE SHE
WAS INTERVIEWED.
LIE.
THAT WAS BEING WRITTEN IN
MAY OF 2016.
THEY INTERVIEWED HER IN JULY
OF 2016.
COMEY SECOND IN COMMAND AT
THE FBI.
ANDREW MCCABE FIRED BECAUSE
OF HIS PATHETIC PATTERN OF
LYING.
SO YOU ARE GOING TO END UP
WITH SOMETHING LIKE THIS IN
HIS LIFE?
WHERE ARE THE FEDERAL CASES
AGAINST ANY OF THESE PEOPLE?
AND THAT'S THE SHORT LIST.
ARE CHARGES GOING TO BE
BROUGHT TO ALL OF THOSE
PEOPLE?
WHEN ARE THE SCREWS GOING TO
BE TURNED SO THEY COMPOSED.
DON'T HOLD YOUR BREATH.
ACCORDING TO MICHAEL GOOD
WIN PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOW
PREPARING AND HE SHOULD BE
PREPARING FOR ALL-OUT
POLITICAL WAR FOR GOOD
REASON.
ROBERT MUELLER AND HIS TEAM,
PARTISAN DEMOCRATS, EVEN
CLINTON ATTORNEYS AND A PIT
BULL THAT LOST 9-0 IN THE
SUPREME COURT COST TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THEIR
JOB ANDREW WEISSMANN AND PUT
FOUR PEOPLE IN JAIL
OVERTURNED BY THE FIFTH
CIRCUIT THEY HAVE SET OUT TO
DISRUPT, DISCREDIT, AND
DESTROY THE PRESIDENCY OF
DONALD J. TRUMP.
NO MATTER HOW MANY LIVES ARE
RUINED IN THE PROCESS.
YOU CAN'T GET HIM ON THE
CRIME, LET'S GET HIM ON A
PROCESS CRIME.
LET'S SET A PERJURY TRAP.
WE HAVE A LOT MORE ALL
THROUGHOUT THE HOUR.
WE WILL CHECK IN WITH
CONGRESSMAN MARK MEADOWS AND
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN AND
MATT GATES.
LET THIS MONOLOGUE BE A
WARNING FOR ANYONE THINKING
ABOUT TRAVELING THROUGH
MEXICO TONIGHT TO CROSS THE
SOUTHERN BORDER ILLEGALLY.
A HANNITY INVESTIGATION, IT
IS NOT EASY AND SAFE.
YOU ARE LITERALLY RISKING
YOUR LIFE.
IF WE HAD A WALL UP PEOPLE
COULD NEVER GET.
IN LIVES WOULD BE SAVED.
LOOK OUGHT THIS FROM THE
A.P.
LAST FOUR YEARS
APPROXIMATELY 4,000 MIGRANTS
HAVE GONE MISSING.
4,000 DURING THEIR TREK
THROUGH MEXICO.
THE A.P. IS ALSO REPORTING
THAT THE TRUE NUMBER IS
LIKELY, QUOTE:  THEIR WORDS,
MUCH HIGHER AND, QUOTE,
BODIES MAY BE LOST IN THE
DESSERT AND FAMILIES MAY NOT
REPORT MISSING LOVED ONES
WHO WERE MIGRANTING
ILLEGALLY.
CARTELS HAVE LONG SCARY
HISTORY AND SLAVING,
MURDERING UNDOCUMENTED
MIGRANTS TRAVELING TOUT U.S.
2010 A MASS GRAVE CONTAINING
72 DEAD MIGRANTS WAS
DISCOVERED.
THEY WERE ALL MURDERED BY A
DANGEROUS GANG CARTEL CALLED
THE ZETES CARTEL.
CARAVAN INCLUDING CHILDREN
KIDNAPPED.
SAME CARTEL REPORTEDLY
RESPONSE CYBIL FOR THOSE WHO
DO SUCCESSFULLY CROSS THE
BORDER ILLEGALLY THE RISKS
CONTINUE IVAN WITHIN THE
UNITED STATES AS THEY TREK
THROUGH RURAL AREAS OF
TEXAS, NORTH OF THE BORDER.
HUNDREDS OF BODIES HAVE BEEN
FOUND.
MANY DYING OF DEHYDRATION
AFTER GETTING LOST IN THE
DESSERT.
AND ONE TEXAS COUNTY ALONE,
OVER 550 BODIES HAVE BEEN
RECOVERED SINCE 2009.
WE TALK ABOUT FAMILY
SEPARATION.
WHAT ABOUT PERMANENT FAMILY
SEPARATION WITH PEOPLE I
DOING?
NOW, MEANWHILE, LOOK AT THIS
VIDEO, FENCING ALONG THE
SOUTHERN BORDER POSES A
SERIOUS RISK FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS LEST WE BUILD A
SUFFICIENT WALL.
SHOCKING VIDEO FROM ARIZONA
SHOWS A SUSPECTED SMUGGLER,
LOOK AT THIS, TOSSING
CHILDREN OVER AN 18-FOOT
BORDER WALL.
OTHERS BELOW ATTEMPTING TO
CATCH THE KIDS, LOOK AT
THIS, ON THE OTHER SIDE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT VIDEO.
ONE AS YOUNG AS 2 YEARS OLD.
IN TIJUANA WHERE THE
MAJORITY OF THE 10,000 PLUS
MEMBERS OF THE MIGRANT
CARAVAN ARE INDEFINITELY
STUCK IN LIMBO, THE
CONDITIONS THERE ARE
HORRIFIC.
THEY FACE SQUALLER CAMP
SITES, INSUFFICIENT
FACILITIES.
RAMPANT DISEASE, A THIRD OF
THE MIGRANTS ARE NOW BEING
TREATED FOR HEALTH-RELATED
ISSUES.
TIJUANA'S HEALTH DEPARTMENT
IS REPORTING THREE CONFIRMED
CASES OF TUBERCULOSIS, FOUR
CASES OF H.I.V. AND AIDES.
FOUR CASE OF CHICKENPOX AND
A HEPATITIS OUTBREAK.
AND, YESTERDAY, DOZENS OF
MIGRANTS ATTEMPTED TO SNEAK
ACROSS THE BORDER NEAR
TIJUANA SCALING A 10-FOOT
METAL FENCE.
THAT'S THE ONE PROBABLY
CHUCK SCHUMER WANTS.
OTHERS WERE ABLE TO SQUEEZE
THROUGH GAPS IN THE FENCING
NEAR THE COAST.
MOST WERE APPREHENDED.
I HAVE NO DOUBT THE MAJORITY
OF MIGRANTS HEADED TO THE
U.S. ARE MERELY IN SEARCH OF
A BETTER LIFE AND MORE
OPPORTUNITY.
THAT'S WHY IF A WALL IS
PROPERLY BUILT, IT WILL
SECURE PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES
AND THE DOOR CAN BE BUILT
AND WE CAN REFORM OUR
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
BUT, BE WARNED, WHILE
IMGRATING INTO THE U.S. IS
ILLEGAL COMING ACROSS
ILLEGALLY CAN TAKE YOUR LIVE
THROUGH THE SOUTHERN BORDER,
VERY HARSH, RISKY, DEADLY,
AND, WE OFTEN REPORT THE
SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION POSES TO THOSE
ALREADY LIVING IN THE U.S. -- SV
ALREADY LIVING IN THE U.S. -- SN
ALREADY LIVING IN THE U.S. -- SY
ALREADY LIVING IN THE U.S. -- SA
ALREADY LIVING IN THE U.S. -- SR
ALREADY LIVING IN THE U.S. -- SP
ALREADY LIVING IN THE U.S. -- SO
ALREADY LIVING IN THE U.S. -- SD
ALREADY LIVING IN THE U.S. -- SI
ALREADY LIVING IN THE U.S. -- SN
TEXAS ALONE.
KEEP IN MIND EVERY SINGLE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT THAT
CROSSES OUR BORDER COSTS YOU
THE TAXPAYERS AROUND 70
GRAND.
LAST YEAR'S TOTAL TAX BILL
WAS A WHOPPING $135 BILLION.
A MASSIVE BORDER WALL WOULD
COST JUST A FRACTION OF
THAT.
AND NOT ONLY WOULD AMERICANS
LITERALLY WILL WOULD HE BE
GIVEN IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITIES HERE TO
CONTROL OUR BORDERS BUT IT
WOULD BE A DETERRENT FOR
PEOPLE THAT WOULD TAKE THAT
TREACHEROUS JOURNEY THROUGH
MEXICO.
SIMPLE SOLUTION TO A
COMPLEX, COSTLY, DANGEROUS
PROBLEM.